hi everybody how's it going i'm excited
because today
i get to talk about wolves with the kala
it was something it was a lot
wizardrying glass was a very long
flashback and wolves with the kala is
back into
crazy action so overall i thought it had
a very great structure i thought the
pros was excellent i mean it's stephen
king
especially late period stephen king this
was written in 2002 i think
um you really feel stephen king develop
as a writer with each
book and in some ways you feel like he
learns and takes an element of a book
and brings it into the next book there
is so much else that is going on i mean
it's a long book and there's a lot of
stuff going on
when people complained to that it was
just a long side
track story where there's like the
quartet gets involved with this
town that needs saving blah blah blah we
don't care let's get back to the tower
i was surprised because this book was
really all about the tower in a lot of
ways there was
a lot of jumping through time there was
a lot of
finding out new information and
mysteries being solved
i will say that this book in a lot of
ways was
a series of long conversations you look
at the cover
and you think wow there's going to be
there's going to be a lot of action in
this there's not a ton of action
there are some great action set pieces
for sure and the ending is action-packed
but
the majority of the book is a lot of
conversations learning about new
characters
here's the thing it almost feels like
books
one two three four were kind of written
without
a clear direction there was not a clear
sense of
okay this is where we're going and i
don't know why i get the sense now
because i know stephen king isn't
necessarily a plotter but i got the
sense reading wolves of the kala
like okay this is the first part of a
trilogy the trilogy being the last three
books of the series
and this is plotted out that there is
a an idea about where this is heading
we have an idea about a destination and
stephen king is setting up a lot of
threads and there are a lot of things to
follow there's a lot of information
dates
details characters events that need to
coincide at the right time
different universes interacting it's
sometimes a lot to
digest and keep up with but you kind of
have to just
trust stephen king to go with it because
he will explain things
you know he won't just leave you behind
really because he's not really that kind
of writer
i will say i enjoyed this better than
wizard and glass i really liked
wizarding glass
i am really excited to finish this
series
the one downside to wolves with the kala
i will say is it's a little
too long probably um i think there's a
little too much
day-to-day stuff going on in the town i
just didn't care that
much about certain characters who live
in the kala
you know it all pays off but i do feel
like certain things could have been
trimmed back
to me this is kind of like a longer a
little more bloated
version of the wastelands so i would put
them on the same
level i love gunslinger and drawing of
the three for totally different
reasons in some way it's hard to rank
the series because they all have
different things that you love about
them
there we have it that's um my
non-spoiler review of wolves of the kala
so spoilers i loved seeing the
interactions between the qatar
and father callahan that may be one of
my favorite parts of this book
was father callahan in preparation for
reading wolves with akala i decided to
take a break from the dark tower read a
few other books i read
salem's lot i read some of hearts and
atlantis but i'm really happy i read
salem's lot uh because
i got a a a better feeling of father
callahan
it wasn't 100 necessary to read salem's
lot i
honestly wouldn't tell people to read
salem slap if you're just reading the
series straight through it's you really
don't have to because you learn what you
need to
um father callahan's backstory that's
recounted in this book i thought it was
going to be like
75 about what happens in salem's lot but
no salem's law is just a tiny little
bit of his story majority of it is about
his wanderings through the united states
his
experiences with the low men and yellow
coats who i discovered in
you know hearts and atlantis there
there's so much that happens
that is really moving and exciting and i
felt like stephen king was kind of
feeling free with this character when he
was writing his point of view and
talking about his
backstory because i even in salem's lot
i felt like stephen king really loved
writing father callahan
and i felt that love returned when he
was writing his character in
uh wolves of the kala some stuff i
didn't really enjoy
completely the situation involving mia
and susanna
and the chap the unborn demon baby
what bothered me about it wasn't that
her you know what's going on what's
going on with her isn't
interesting it's very interesting but
because it felt like there was needless
drama
in within the quartet it reminded me uh
in some ways of what happens in certain
fantasy series or tv shows where
characters hide information from each
other like a group of characters will
hide information from each other
needlessly to cause some sort of tension
or drama that doesn't really have to be
there
that's kind of what i felt was happening
you know roland knows about what's
happening with susannah
but chooses not to tell susannah chooses
not to tell eddie
uh when jake finds out he you know
doesn't want jake to tell them and then
uh eddie finds out he doesn't want eddie
to tell susannah unto
until susanna just finally finds out for
herself so it's just like
but that's really my only gripe with it
other stuff i really enjoyed
i absolutely love stuff that recalls the
earlier books i love
you know the wastelands i love uh the
drawing of the three and anytime they go
back
to like new york in 1977 it's just fun
i loved eddie um coming back to new york
and kicking ass with
um balazar's henchmen in the bookstore
and then of course that ending which
brings everything together
you know after we find out that the
wolves of the kala
are using lightsabers from star wars
they're using snitches from harry potter
except the snitches just like
blow a person up and just like eat out
their intestines which is so cool i love
that
i came into the series knowing a lot of
these spoilers not all of them
i definitely don't know how the series
goes please don't spoil anything for me
because but i just had the idea i knew
that stephen king
as himself as the writer was going to
play a major part later in the series
i knew that wolves of the kala crazy
stuff's gonna happen with you know the
lightsabers and the snitches and
all that sort of stuff and that things
are going to get really
meta i had that idea and because of that
i felt like i could really enjoy the
series
better because i knew what i was getting
into and to me
that was like what i was really looking
forward to when i started the series i
was like man i can't wait to get to
those later books because things are
going to get really crazy
when father callahan you know reads
salem's lot at the end of this book
and is saying like i'm not a fictional
character
i love that stuff so much uh the
characters starting to question their
own existence in the book it just
to me it doesn't break my immersion it
just it makes it even more immersive
because i'm like wow i am part of these
characters
story of them realizing they're in this
book
potentially you know i don't really know
what happens after this i haven't had
this much fun with a series
in a long time i will go on to say that
i'm
enjoying the dark tower more than uh
even the stormlight archive
it just um breaks a lot of rules that i
find really fun
i just really hope that it doesn't
disappoint me
at the end that's how i feel about the
series this is how i feel about the dark
tout or this is how i feel about wolves
of the kala
my other reviews of the series are up on
the channel and uh thank you for
watching